well joining us now is the mayor of
london at sadiq khan uh thank you very
much for being on the program and mr
khan what's your response to last trust
as victory
well on a personal level i sincerely
congratulate liz trust and being elected
the conservative leader today
she'll be the prime minister uh tomorrow
we may come from different political
traditions but she was a councillor in
london between 2006 and 2010. i'm hoping
that uh what unites us
is our common desire to see a capital
city flourishing and thriving but also
our country succeeding
do you think she's a person that you
could work with
we need to
we need to put aside a part of little
difference
we need to avoid this anti-london stuff
we've seen over the last two three years
we need to avoid pitching communities
and people against one another
because of a culture wall and work
together to address saw and inflation to
work together to address the rise in
energy prices work together to keep the
head above water of those families those
communities those businesses that are
looking to the prime minister and myself
for leadership and working together
just to come in what what do you mean by
could anti-london a sort of rhetoric
that we've seen you talk about the
leveling up agenda there
well look some people perceive
leveling up as meaning
making london poorer that certainly is
one way to make our country more level i
think it's nonsensical particularly when
before the pandemic we as the capital
city contributed net 40 billion pounds
to the treasury which is then
distributed around the country for
example our public transport in london
suffered hugely because londoners did
the right thing and stayed at home so we
need support from the government in the
short term to make sure public transport
works in london that ensures our
businesses can have workers get into
their offices and tourists getting
around our city it makes no sense to
punish londoners by solving tfl of
support and there are other examples of
pots of funding from the government that
we are able to bid for so what i'm
saying is look i understand the
importance of making our country more
equal one of the ways of doing that is
by devolving more powers and resources
to manchester to liverpool to sheffield
sheffield and london so we can all you
know flourish and thrive rather than
london struggling and as a consequence
our country's struggling too i spoke to
west streeting the shadow health
secretary a little bit earlier on this
afternoon and he told me that he would
like to see liz trust call an election
but she doesn't have a mandate she can't
break away
from the manifesto in a democratic way
without calling an election do you agree
with that well if this trust is going to
be continuity of boris johnson then i
think the british public deserve the
opportunity to vote for a fresh start
under key osama and the labour party
many of the issues that are causing this
national crisis have been exacerbated by
the government of the last 12 years look
at these strikes which are a symptom of
12 years of austerity where those in the
public sector in particular have seen
peka after paco over the last 12 years
look at the cost of energy in the uk
versus the cost of energy in the
european union and across the world so
look if list trust is continuity boris
johnson
to theresa may then i think we do need a
general election to give the british
public the option of a fresh start under
cure some with fresh different policies
or continuation of the conservatives
which we've seen over the last 12 years
causing real problems around the country
boris johnson was an election winner
wasn't he do you think that he would
have been a more formidable opponent
than liz trust
well he's the past
i'm keen to talk about the future
and liz trust is the future prime
minister of our country from tomorrow i
want to reset relations between me the
mayor of london and the mayor of the
capital city uh and the the new prime
minister i think what we need to do is
to stop seeing north versus south or
older versus younger or one faith versus
another what we want to see what we
deserve is a prime minister governor in
the national interest rather than
governing in the narrow part of
political interest
okay uh mayor of london thank you very
much indeed for being on the program
today